starting your episode with a visual role
commercials metaphor in your episode
title cliche also that's right we'll
continue totaling up the sins as sin
juan because there's no better way to
prove math sucks than by doing lots of
math plus the current conversion rate is
six 1166 point six the episode title is
hell so it's clear we're all doing the
devil's work today i don't know if it's
their garish color scheme the whimsical
music that accompanies them or their
generally nonchalant attitude towards
death but these guys always remind me of
willy wonka's oompa-loompas and suddenly
this whole operation makes a lot more
sense to me this is a moody shot and all
but you're telling me that not one of
these remaining participants would still
be screaming or crying or pacing around
searching for an escape even if they
were in shock wouldn't it be more
comfortable to be in shock in your bunk
but no someone was like hey we've got
all these beds and this is a giant room
but let's all huddle silently sitting on
the floor together for maximum downer
vibes cool son
you helped me thank you no he did not
what he did was call your name which
made you turn your head which should
have resulted in your death although
with this show i wouldn't be surprised
if that was the idea all along
we covered this last time but it bears
mentioning again this english dub is
terrible then it doesn't even need to be
there's a huge community of fantastic
voice artists out there you think long
and hard about that while we convert
your 20 tv sins into sin juan i still
need to name my child sir
procrastination also does it make anyone
else uncomfortable that out of the group
of 200 or so people most of which appear
to be men that the first three to beg
for their life are all women i'm just
saying i'd have demolished everyone in
that room if a grovel contest was the
game reinforce gender stereotypes be
damned
there seems to be a misunderstanding a
misunderstanding of the situation would
have required the participants to have
had said situation fully explained to
them in the first place yes the rules of
the game and the cash prize at the end
of it were all explained but there was
also the very salient omission of being
[ __ ] murdered if you fail why isn't
that in the contract if you just follow
the rules you can leave this place
safely with the prize money we promised
well that's a lie in future games you
also have to win you could absolutely
follow the rules and still be killed
sure lying to them might make sense but
in a show that seems to be saying the
goal is about order and rules and
legitimate contracts these kinds of
blatant falsifications stand out consent
form clause 3 if all the players agree
to stop playing the games are allowed to
end or am i wrong the contract we saw in
episode one consisted of three very
basic clauses and yet sangwoo is
presenting this clause through
revelation as if he's discovered some
fundamental loophole in the magnifying
garda also this piggy bank's on for 35
seconds damn could they not have used
larger denominations also also the piggy
bank makes for a nice motivational
visual but unless they actually intend
on sending the winner out with 45.6
billion won in a few dozen briefcases
what's the point having the cash
physically there is a huge security risk
be they on a deserted island or not and
it appears the pig nostrils are open you
never leave the pig nostrils open
amateurs if you wish to continue playing
press the green button with an o if you
wish to stop playing then please press
the red button with the x instead hold
menus if we stop right now that only
helps the ones who are dead
they get 100 million one and not us
arguments that you think sound really
convincing but simply expose you as the
insensitive and immoral squid that you
really are
we will not condone any kind of act that
impedes this democratic process
therefore any acts we do condone are by
default promoting the democratic process
oink it seems we're down to the last
vote because of course it came down to
the last [ __ ] vote which means that
they were either all deliberately
keeping it 50 50 because none of them
wanted to fully commit to either option
or it's down to dumb luck that they just
happened to be split right down the
middle what would have happened if there
were an even number of players left also
why wasn't this voting in the
accompanying vote counter anonymous
surely being able to see the result in
real time has the potential to skew the
final result come on guys it can't be
that hard to implement a fair voting
system that everyone agrees with oh oh
look there's the form of a stick figure
playing what appears to be tug of war
i'm sure that must mean something and in
a group this size someone will explore
the room enough to find it and it will
result in all sorts of discoveries can't
wait for that to happen the doctor said
there's a
lump inside over here growing every day
brain tumor unnecessary flashback
expositional reminders if the majority
of you wish to participate again then we
will resume the game but how exactly you
send 201 people back out into the world
and then you just wait for 101 of them
to give you a call from the card do you
assume those that voted to stay will
always want to come back so you just
need one person to call what if a stay
vote finds love and stability outside
the game can they change their vote in
the same way someone who wanted to leave
can what if they lose the card change
their phone number how do they track
them this is a fun little twist but the
details on how when and why you would
get all these people back are vague at
best and impossible at worst but also
the choice to put the games on pause and
send them back to their lives may be the
most brilliant part of this entire
show's structure it allows us to see the
driving concept of the games and then
releases us to not only feel more of the
backstories but truly understand the
similarity of their real-life existence
to the game itself it solidifies the
metaphor in such a real way that i can't
help but take off a couple sin juan for
the choice hurry up now
oh that hurts
hey
hey stop
come on it's my turn now dialogue of my
sex tape i swear i'll forget the whole
thing how can i trust you i swear on my
on my own mother okay this works and yes
we mean it both ways gihon's money boner
is apparently so strong it wouldn't even
wait to allow him to untie his feet so
he wouldn't have to haplessly and
hopelessly hop at the pickpocket
mondays you've got to realize what a
massive deal all this was i know it
sounds crazy it seems like the show
wants us to believe the police never get
involved because of how ridiculous the
whole story sounds but there are 201
people who just left this game at least
100 of which were itching to get out of
there they all have cards they all have
eyewitness accounts they might even be
able to describe some of those who were
killed i'm just saying hiding this game
is probably a bit more complex than no
one will believe you so you're saying
that your kidnappers rounded up hundreds
of people and had them play a game then
went out there and shot the ones who
lost previously on squid game then give
us the killer's description they all had
these masks on the whole time we were
there or you could just describe the guy
at the subway station who definitely
wasn't wearing a mask and is probably
still out there recruiting people but no
apparently the show thinks it's more
entertaining for the police to believe
gihan is an idiot so play the part of
the idiot he shall here's the number
it's on a business card call it and see
what they say the one piece of physical
evidence that gihan has and he's waited
until after he's explained everything in
the vaguest way possible and all the
cops think he's actually insane before
he decides to share it this lidless
container and its potential keyboard
ruining contents
it is by no means impossible but it sure
is lucky giehung swings by here right as
sengwu is spying on his mother dumb luck
when you can't be bothered to write
something convincing you haven't been
home in days now
out doing whatever it is you're doing
lately but now you're a good son huh
gihon's mom would be inspector royale at
tv sins remember you ended it and used
up all the cash we had exposition
induced amnesia is just the worse for
everyone a police officer have you
forgotten that is he asking his mom or
us sorry sometimes i can't tell with how
often the show feels the need to remind
us of obvious things we already know
well isn't this the most convenient
episode of conveniences or what junhoe
just happens to be at the front desk of
the police station at the perfect time
to notice the squid game business card
being on show so that he'd have a lead
later on when he finds the same business
card in his brother's apartment you just
couldn't write this stuff was he drunk
some crazy hobo guy everything's crazy
around here today unnecessary repeat
sins about unnecessary flashback
expositional reminders abandoning an
occupied stroller someone called teddy
bear protective services let me think
about it
something like sang or song or something
and how about getting me his address too
gihon's name is causing all sorts of
issues but his address no [ __ ]
problem let me just pull it up on my
database i think i have it filed under
moving the plot along it would be
amazing if these episode two moments for
the characters foreshadowed something
for them later in the show i'd take a
sin one off for that for sure oh well
probably not i imagine getting that to
work would be too much of a pain in the
neck you pull anything on me
i'll rip your [ __ ] throat wide open
and that's that i'm not sure how
effective a throat ripping will be on a
man who can clearly take third degree
burns to 100 of his face as if it were
nothing more than a caffeine enriched
facial pack
does she keep doing that in this shot
the pocket is completely intact and the
camera doesn't move from her the entire
time she has him in knife point yet now
the pocket has been sliced open and the
contents presumably lifted is she hiding
six extra arms is she this game's actual
squid
[Music]
squid mame i'm afraid that mr chosun wu
has a warrant out for his arrest these
[ __ ] police officers burst into
sangwoo's mother's business while she's
in mid-transaction to accuse her son of
embezzlement and fraud i'm sure they're
desperate to find him but could they not
have just waited 60 seconds for her to
finish up instead of embarrassing her in
front of this customer misunderstanding
the term bathing suit
[Applause]
[Music]
who is it
why did the person at the door ring the
doorbell for all this time if they're
just going to slip the note under the
door anyway why not just ring the bell a
few times slip the card under it and
leave so that i didn't have to be
triggered by the feeling of walking
around soaking wet while fully clothed
wait so everyone's just getting one of
these new cards and they all just show
back up not a single one of these
calamari competitors found something
better in life than going back to the
place that might brutally murder them
sure i sinned it already once but if the
show's gonna keep complicating this
catch and release and then catch again
program i'm gonna keep on sitting it
i'll continue my chauffeuring and come
help around here this line doesn't lead
to a parasite squid game connected
universe connected universes are the
only true entertainment damn it coming
out to someone's nice pub and smoking
outside's roof citation needed what are
the odds you're here at the same time as
me
what are the odds right this is like the
fifth time these two have exclaimed how
crazy it is that they're meeting like
this so i put the odds that show uses
the only random meeting that is
intentional to pound home the
convenience because it makes them look
better later to one something about
friday nights always brings out the
weirdos that's friday nightist parking
in a driving lane on a bridge hey look
here you jerk oh yeah well a jerk is a
tug and a tug is a boat and a boat
floats on water and water is nature and
nature is beautiful so thank you what i
just figured if the show is going with
grade school insults i should go with
grade school come back since and now
you're gonna die you [ __ ] [ __ ] in
the future sir may i recommend exiting
the vehicle of the former gang boss who
you've just admitted to betraying before
prematurely celebrating harder than a 10
year old who doesn't realize that the
t-rex shape present under the tree is
actually a giraffe they're not the same
mom okay it would be amazing if these
episode two moments for the characters
foreshadowed something for them later in
the show i'd take a sinhoan off for that
for sure oh well i imagine the show will
cross that bridge when it comes to it
you know i watched that guy die with my
own eyes
but no hospital though he couldn't go
honey
we're home judging by this entry the
stepdad and kids somehow apparently
didn't hear any of this borderline
skipworthy ruckus
golf wait
it seems that gehan's ex-wife not only
managed to explain the situation with
his mother but also managed to convince
the step dad to pull out the equivalent
of two thousand dollars put it in an
envelope while still leaving enough time
to catch up to gihon before he'd barely
made it 20 steps out of the building
that's some unbelievable efficiency i
mean it it's literally unbelievable do
you think muddy stalls everything dad
why you know it's not helped by the
already mentioned terrible dub but even
without it this show really does teeter
into melodrama at times maybe they
should have named the show battle royale
with cheese instead of slipping it under
the door like they did at sengwu's place
the squid game [ __ ] decide to leave
gihon's invite sticking out of the door
where it can easily get lost or ruined
by the weather quality my ass cool we
now know why v6 all decided to willingly
re-enter the gee hunger games only 95
more backstories to go for it all to
make sense
[Music]
zeibach doesn't understand how knockout
gas works and yet this [ __ ] works
[Music]
by the power of god
i condemn you back to hell i'm getting
better no you're not you'll be stone
dead in a moment all right as you wish
that day she was amazed to discover that
when he was saying as you wish
what he meant was i love you
over the hills and far away
teletubbies come to play
[Music]
get me loose
get me the hell come on get me out of
here come on get me out of here cut me
loose damn it do you have a boyfriend
no you never told me your name
why do you want to know my name i want
to know who i'm looking at